welcome to the recruitment rollercoaster
podcast my name is Hisham Aziz and today
I'm joined by Arjun Gillard who is the
head of dot net understanding
recruitment currently managing a team of
two people and looking to grow in 2020
and beyond Arjun thank you for joining
me thanks for having me and looking
forward to this one and as you know
where I always like to start my friends
obviously we're talking before we
started this new experience in uni and
doing archaeology how-how-how the
dodging end up into the wonderful world
of recruitment my friend how did that
happen yes it was basically I didn't
know what I wanted to do the standard
recruitment thing yeah I thought I was
going to manage a bar after unique I was
doing that whilst at uni yeah and my dad
sort of had a phone call with him I was
like yeah I'm gonna stay in New York for
a bit manager bar see what happens and
yeah got told to [ __ ] yes he said he
said that's all well and good but get a
career you were in in stupid amount of
debt really I was like yeah right made
sense so I just put high paid office
jobs into Google yeah and literally
recruitment kept coming up really yes I
was like what I was like what the hell
is recruitment I never known about it no
one talks to you about that at school or
you knew or anything so I did a bit of
research into it and had a couple of
interviews and like Leeds and Manchester
excited misses at the time in York and
she was like I'll get a job like round
here yeah and then had one interview in
London came came all the way down here
really yeah literally like spoke to him
on the phone and they were like I'll
come down to London I was like right
yeah get on a train stayed with my mom
and dad and then you had the into got
grilled for an hour and a half really
then near then told to go away and have
a coffee and then got offered a job like
then and there but told you need to
accept like on the sport yeah yeah
actually like oh yeah we want you to
join but like the is light yeah a lot
accept it that's what it offers not that
yeah that's what it is basically well
that's that's how it felt like I had a
couple of offers in Manchester I didn't
tell them that a lot of you've got a few
things done yeah yeah I said I've got a
couple of offers in Manchester but to be
fair blah I was pretty sold on it really
and yeah I was like I was bought into
what they said so I thought yeah I'll
take it hadn't told my girlfriend at
that time yeah what was what was going
on I just said I've gotten into in
London yeah we all went out for drinks
and like I got a little bit drunk yeah
and she called me at about nine o'clock
at night so now where are you I was like
I'm out with my new bosses yeah she was
really she didn't join now she was still
at uni really am so yeah I tried to make
the long-distance thing work for I think
it probably worked for about four months
yeah that was about it this and that
London recruitment going out and
drinking Thursday and Friday
I mean drive to your o'clock on a Friday
night if I don't okay very quickly then
before we sort of unpack your
recruitment career how am how did they
sell recruitment was the recruitment
pitch core sinking back a long time now
but it was it was pretty much the
standard was like four holidays a year
like oh you'll earn 40k your first year
like aeu second hundred your third and
and that you get a Rolex and all that
sort of thing yeah which me and like I
was about 22 sort of four years at uni
so I was just like yeah yeah I want as
much cash as possible I like the sound
of that so yeah I was pretty do you
regret
do you regret that's uni yeah part of me
does vide yeah
oh well part of me doesn't part of me
doesn't yeah yeah cuz I was like 35
grand in debt or something but I had a
good time like I met loads of decent
mates the summer flights still my best
mates now yeah and like I just went how
I'm like worked in bars going to
but I didn't I basically saw uni as my
part-time job and been in a bar was my
full-time job still not 40 50 60 hour
weeks working in bars and then I never
went to uni mate but as we just said
before like a lot of people which it's a
challenge writers parents wanted to go
to uni
yeah they feel like a lot of people feel
like they have to go to uni now see it's
massively changing right but yeah that's
a bit like me to be fair like my mum
basically was like you've got to go to
uni and I had no idea why one day I
think I applied to one role which was
criminology and I was like yeah now I
ended up staying at college for another
year
yeah remember an EMA yeah yeah basically
you got fake weird week yeah yeah see a
few parents and ex and I stayed for a
third year at college because the last
year of EMA right and me and my mates
did a plumbing course one of our best
mates is a plumber now and that's his
business but I would absolutely crumble
mate
yeah so I try to get that it's hard
right know what you want to do and all
that I guess do you feel like now
recruitment is your career yeah yeah
yeah I think that I don't think there's
anything that I'd want to do other than
this because it is multifaceted its
marketing in sales
yeah it's just everything rolled into
one so I think yeah I love it
thought you said that mate I think big
part of the podcast is trying to like
make it then on that last you making
recruitment a choice a career choice
yeah is a good career choice right yeah
yeah you know I mean and okay cool so
let's unpack if everyone listening then
so join that business and you worked
there for seven was it seven or eight
years yeah seven and our theatre not so
never worked some equipment before
very sharp and recruitment stayed there
for nearly a decade yes a long time yes
see that many that often on TVs now in
terms of working for a recruitment
company for that long and then obviously
and
you'll rip their comedy work for now she
was at June or July July last year yeah
cool
so let's definitely unpack the sort of
seven or so years so what was the
typical route there and so joined as a
training I'm assuming yes oh and rookie
whatever and then crime the typical
ranks of yeah yeah so I started as a
trainee yeah
struggled as everyone does took me three
months to do my first deal yeah then was
promoted to consultant I think about
five months in then senior consultant 14
months in when I started to build a team
yeah straight away from that which was
intense
yes didn't really know what the hell I
was still there then yeah principle team
leader head of division and then when
you left you as head of the division
yeah yeah so I said if I was head of
engineering and construction and then
moved into si P recruitment for about
five months as well and then that's when
I decided to uncover that so yeah when
you got to the head of part how many
people you manage in ten ten yeah yeah
yeah was it just your management
responsibilities just increased
basically and sort of evolved yes what
typically appellants pretty much so when
I got to ten people I was off the phone
then yeah so then I was just a manager
you know like growing the team
influencing doing some BD and and that
sort of thing but up until that point of
the way always a billing manager which
to begin with I've struggled with mmm
because I didn't I couldn't manage my
own time yeah always let's talk about it
mmm how was that for you mate humor
still Winfrey might at three months in
yeah so I did my first deal in January
2012 from the candidates name yeah
[Laughter]
[Music]
so - yeah three or ten months - yeah
he'll and then yeah so Jan 2012 to
December 2012 I did 140k really yeah
yeah it's alright to be fertile Pam yeah
all Pam yeah I was always perm I did a
couple of contract deals but yeah
primarily perm year so what what do you
think enabled you to achieve that do you
think looking back or thinking about
what what do you think some of the
things that contributed to to be able to
do 100 foot weekend in first year I
struggled in my first year like
literally it was I think they like
pushed me to a point where they thought
I was going to quit because I just I was
so crap for the first couple of man what
makes you proud what do you think made
you proud
I just couldn't beats people I thought I
was asking the right questions and I
just wasn't
hmm and then I wasn't I wasn't doing the
right things like I was I was able to
pull jobs with like multiple companies
but then I'd send like one CV to CVS and
have one into you at like loads of
different companies yeah and they're
yourself enough opportunity yeah pretty
much that and then I sort of sat down
with my director and just went through
it all and said look work fewer jobs but
work them into the ground and then
that's when it started to pick up for me
really and then yeah I just literally
did the same thing but I was working
half 7:00 in the morning to like half 8
9 o'clock at night just a yeah just to
get good cuz yeah I was just crashed
really fit and put in the grass yeah I
literally just put a shift in what what
would how would have any sort of jobs at
the end that was sort of typically
focusing on them what did it ended up
sort of narrowing down my yeah my name
was probably about I'd say I'd solidly
work four or five a month and then aim
to fill three or four a chap called Tom
who says that he sort of always
encourages his team to have like four
opportunities permanent like for
opportunities to make placement yeah it
seemed quite good quite a good barometer
lie and that's not just one interview
neat just like solid ng still aim for
that now
yeah bottle is metric to aim for that
gives you the best chance of closing off
what you want yeah pretty much I still
aim for four or five solid jobs a month
live like four or five inches at first
stage three inches at second stage and
then I'm like right I should be doing at
least something each month what do you
think no me no now what do you think
makes a job a solid job
rules of engagement we used to call it
at my old place it's like actually
having a hiring manager who's committed
to hire like on like just having things
in place so when you when you qualify in
the job right so I'm gonna send you five
CVS by 24 hours or 48 hours whatever it
is let's book in a time to speak through
your CVS at this time like when you're
talking about the the job when can you
into an absolutely nailing down like
specific days and into times and then
like what happens after the first stage
what like the second stage when's that
going to be when have you got booked in
for that who with who with a person be
meeting and I just truly understand what
the hell's going on yeah and if they're
not giving you that commitment I don't
work it yeah because I'm slight now
you're not serious about hiring I'll
send one or two Seavey's just to like
see what it is yeah and if they then
come back committed then yeah fine off I
work other than that I'm just like you
definite finding all that out at the
beginning I are nice I remember I still
remember when I pulled my first job yeah
I was like cool off completely really
loved that and again it like it sounds
simple and this man came up in the past
but like it's the it's the basic so you
gotta get really right if you're if
you're having if you're getting all
those details with four or five
businesses four or five hundred managers
a mum for the same sort of people per
month one job so that they're hiring for
yeah there's even better chance there
and you can actually have a real good
idea than the right case I've got
obviously a couple of people at first
days called people the second stage and
you've got an a natural proper time line
they're not like right this is this
when it could drop and this is when I
could placement rather than not sure
when they're doing the final stages that
you know I'm in yeah is that something
you live and I sort of died by now then
yeah pretty much like I literally I look
at my calendar every day and I'm like
I've color-coordinate all my calendar on
Outlook so I know what candidates are
interviewing on what dates I'm like
right cause I've got this this and this
and if I haven't got like if my calendar
is not read with the category all right
crap on it yourself some CDs in or on it
there's a new jobs on it yeah and then
that also ties in that also helps you
understand where you need to be putting
your easel sometime exactly yeah exactly
that okay me why didn't you quit in that
first year there mate because 7th I mean
obviously when we just chat before we
walked in here working from home today
yeah 7:30 to 8:30 p.m. they change that
I mean to be fair the couple of times
and sort of there's no sort of set and
background that gives you the best
possible chance of being successful
recruitment but obviously working in a
bar job it was [ __ ] hard graft you
mean yeah a couple of times like
hospitality can be a quite good
background cuz I got that work ethic and
these things but why do you think he
didn't quit early on because that could
have prevented a lot of people quitting
he'd burn out a lot you know I mean why
did you think he didn't quit I think it
was a combination of two things it was
personal pride no I just don't like
losing long I never have I don't think
well I don't think anyone likes Lee yeah
but it just I get that knot in my
stomach when you're not doing well so
that was you've always had that yeah
I've always had that either points
proved to like my directors because they
like they thought I was gonna quit he's
like why do you think they've why do you
think they've felt like you didn't quit
I think just because I was really
struggling really yeah I was just really
struggling enough that the thought that
probably thought eyes probably just
thinks it's too hard he's gonna Jack it
in but so that was a point to prove and
just like my mum and dad I can say okay
yeah it was yeah it was mainly like like
having an Indian mum it was almost like
as always are you got to get the best
education yeah like decent a stars A's
at GCC
that's going to vary coming back as a
federal cruising even one mom I'm not
doctor go away yeah pretty much
we're not said I was going into
recruitment she know me I love the
honesty there so just real just real
personal drivers ever knocked a bell I
love that mate so did you do you think
did you feel like you had like a second
option or like that was it like this was
it you know I mean did you feel like
right if it goes wrong I descend that
back in Basel was that not an option to
you yeah it wasn't really an option here
cuz I'd moved from York to London so I'd
like left that bar life behind lot
obviously I could have got a job in
London but I didn't want say I wasn't
that high paying off his job yeah pretty
much that yeah and when I was kept
googling so much about okay so year to
then mmm clearly obviously boots and
momentum
yeah then so by that point you was a
senior concern yes you can start in year
two so how what sort of them enabled you
to progress them how was that measured
was it just a non Billings or was it
done on sort of other things yeah it was
just spilling was there it was when we
first started out it wasn't deal value
it was number of deals you're doing so I
had to do seven over three months really
basically but I mean my first actual
targets a hit senior was literally just
don't do don't blank in December really
like and I blanked in December I'd like
yeah I think I'd about 35 inches and put
I was literally pulling my hair out and
then yeah that happened and they were
like right this is what your target is
so I pretty much nailed that in like two
months and then got promoted and then
yeah started hiring a couple of months
after that what and did you want that I
didn't want it at that time to be fair
but that was just that was the structure
yeah cuz it was like I was the first
hire with two other people so they
wanted to grow and like they had been
one yeah
yeah I was the first high with two
others there's four of you in his life
yeah yeah there was three directors
three other people like a couple of
other people in the business my talking
about x4 here right yeah
they're big business right yeah about
150 now with newest multiple officers on
his leash for Abuna right yeah yeah they
tell you that like it was that I think
that's why I struggled so much because
it was like it was an office environment
and that was just small yeah and like
when when Noah was on the phone you can
you knew no one was on the phone when
you were the only one on the phone like
you could hear yeah everyone was
listening and not I could just tell when
I [ __ ] up a cause I ran off to the
boardroom with like my director to go
through that call and the walls were
thin and everyone could hear yeah that
was that was a tough toughness but I
fired off that line I really know yeah
exactly so it's just literally like just
get on with it crack on and that's it
yeah because I just had the perception
of what they are now so I didn't realize
that so that makes sense since they
obviously wanted to scale yeah exactly
Osman was also one of the early hires
we've Tufton toughen them up he's gone
through a lot of stuff he's had to get
through so mm make sense that you can
now manage yeah I've got him hid in his
lunch club like his first billion month
like he joined and then his next month
got him doing three deals really like
yeah he off to a good start because he
basically had my market in the north of
Midlands and I'd already established
like like yeah so I just basically said
work this role I'll send that candidate
like and yeah yeah then year - hmm
managed that whole time then there's
this on and how many people was just the
one person not yeah it was one to begin
me I think I hired someone else towards
the end of the year yeah as well but we
went we always had quite good retention
right but I just had a couple of people
that like left fourth in my count yeah
one
parents I think parents didn't want him
to be in London anymore so he moved away
and then the other one wasn't that good
and then the aired like then started to
grow and what did the team get to them
by the time I left I had 20 people
underneath me like mixture of trainees
consultants team leads really like
business development people and that
yeah so you to to sort of year for then
yeah we'll do that all again so by that
point what was it like team intern no
that was about I think up to about four
I had five people underneath me really
yeah year four it was me billing I was
always billing I was always one of the
top builders I'm just growing them
getting them good and then yeah it was
only after like year for that where I
started to hire more and more people
more regularly yeah let's just talk
about that for a second yes I think I I
never
I've never done the role but you were
you always here obviously billion
manager being really difficult yeah how
how did you met how did you maintain
your buildings while managing it how did
you maintain that sort of a little bit
and it took free once managing just
working longer really really yeah really
and it was it was that but also being
smart with my time like with the jobs I
was actually working okay so like if I
just thought yeah it's not worth my time
at all it really is your time yeah I
just wouldn't work it and I did I did
the same thing pretty much every day
like come in first thing in the morning
Dharma leads gone like the job boards
see what new candidates are out there
and then like Bedi or work a job that I
needed to do and then I just always set
myself like I wouldn't go home until I
did X or until I did Y and they talk
about and I'm assuming you the same day
plan what did a typical building manager
day planet like then because you'll see
your billing manager now on yeah so
whereas it took Woods was involved in
that day how have you structured it so
yeah pretty much the same thing like
darling my leads first thing in the
morning yeah
go now LinkedIn recruiter so save
searches are still used some job boards
yeah it just basically go through all
those get my messages out yeah and then
just think about what I need to do so is
it BD morning call sourcing morning for
jobs awesome how would the world how do
you how do you decide that I just how
many TVs I've got outstanding we do with
the companies actually like sort of
pipeline them yeah interview got bitten
yeah pretty much that so yeah have I got
enough CVS that there have I got enough
into jean-guy and that's yeah how does
how does the management aspect fit into
all this
so what the one of the people on
managing now has got like two and a half
three years experience say he's pretty
self-sufficient I'll catch up with him
like obviously we talk every day and
they're live like two one-on-one
meetings a week with him that's
literally it
my new start who started in January end
of Jan he's already like not
self-sufficient but he's confident and
competent enough that he knows what he's
doing so he sits next to me so I'm just
like if you need help ask me yeah and
like when he like if he's mixing his
search things up or if he's doing
something yeah I'll sit and watch him so
cuz I'll just literally turn my head
like that and watch him do it and then
yeah then crack on with it yeah and then
calm down so that's now but what no and
he was growing that team wonder that
little like difficult yeah that was
difficult was it quite reactive I think
so yeah I think so cuz I was I was
literally being pulled here there and
everywhere so like one minute I was
doing internally and she's one minute I
was doing training lighting training new
stars and next minute I had to do like
cool coaching him cool listening it was
just basically what I did with sourcing
or like my own business whenever I had
time to actually do my own thing I was
just like right head down don't talk to
anyone
yeah and just literally didn't
communicate that like look guys like if
you like absolutely have to grab you
that's fine but I'm gonna be doing this
yeah pretty much I said it's like I
always said there's no stupid question
yeah but like if someone was just like
always
like where's Oxford or something
yes being just cracked on there's an
element as well obviously when you're
going through that process there you
also don't want to be the comfort
blanket for these people yeah do you
know I mean it's like if you if they
always ask you questions that they may
know the answers to burn do not I mean I
think yeah there was up I've found that
tough when I first started managing off
that comfort blanket because the first
couple of people I literally poured my
heart and soul into training them and it
because it was I saw them as an
extension of me yeah so I thought they
need to be seen it's good around a bit
yeah and everything like that so yeah
but I think that may have had a negative
effect on them in like second or third
years for them when my team grew more
and more and I'll spend less time yeah
yeah so that's it is yeah can be hard to
get that balance there right is yeah
because sometimes I think I like one of
the mistakes I made I went full tilt and
didn't give him enough support from day
one and like then they really struggled
through it and then I had to pick him up
like six months in a year in and yeah
yes just literally I always learn from
my mistakes that it's just like making
them and then billions wise then mmm
year for right now what's of like how
what did you do roughly like if you can
remember if you've got some in the top
yeah 200 yeah 200 with a team of 5 200
with a team of seven I was hovered
around a hundred eighty to two hundred
with my team like when yeah when I had a
bigger team and that how to do that yeah
you know I mean some people want to do
them and it's just them doing and
everything yeah all they got worried
about has themselves do you know I mean
yeah obviously I know you said like you
put in the hours
yeah I'm just thinkin if there's
anything else they're like did you like
what was a set up did you have did you
folk that you focus on clients and
getting in the jobs and then you had you
did a lot of splits that contribute to
that no it was all my own business we
didn't I did everything I didn't have
resources everyone that started was a
360 consoling
from day one I was dear you literally
used speaking to candidates for the
first week and speaking to clients from
the second week really yeah yeah you is
sort of maintained and got even the
management team that was all through
like arjen's relationships and you
delivering sauce and crying yeah yeah
someone passed me over jobs yeah yeah
yeah it wasn't like we didn't have split
so you'd get 25% of that right yeah
that's at that stage it wasn't like that
I think it is there now but yeah but
when you're growing that team yeah yeah
yeah that's been really difficult it was
yeah it was just literally it was just
hard work really just dear just working
longer hours and just literally being
smart with your time always when I was
having more people underneath me I
wouldn't really work a role under 20%
19% that sort of thinkers and it was
like 45 50 K salaries as a minimum just
because I was like if I'd if I could
make one placement a month at 12 K 13 K
that's better then yeah that's better
than doing one for K deal yeah so yeah
so I was interested nothing like that
that's the insight in there I think
clearly as you as you progression you
know sort of career you can use really
really valued your time yeah and as you
said back to sort of your advice and
your process of working with hiring
managers that committed to you being
committed to the right jobs to you only
work and then set fees that again it's
running your time yeah as you said they
give you the best possible chance and
that when you do allocate resource the
the resource we put in towards that give
you the best possible return that you
could get interesting insight
yeah so why why do you think you sort of
progressed compared to other people run
you may be like why do you think you got
to the head of position because you just
took the tip like so obviously that
continued to evolve you then got ahead
of that that team right yeah why do you
think that is I think it's just because
I was always like always willing to do
things really like yeah I just I was
always there put in the work like yeah
just a work ethic like at the AGM is the
first two years they introduced a leader
of the
Year award and I won that the first year
and then won it in the next year and
yeah just because of like the work I was
doing I was just always on hand to help
people and like yeah just to do whatever
I could I don't actually know because
I've naturally I'm not an empathetic
person like yeah it's a lot my friends
and family I'm like I hate people I
don't really know I think it's I think
cause I hired those people and I saw
them as an extension of myself yeah I
want to get you good I want to get you
doing doing well so I think it I think
it was justified yeah yeah yeah just
hold yourself in high esteem and like
hold others around you in the same same
category really do you think he'd go
back and start that that whole process
again do you think anything differently
yeah I'd realize what I've realized now
that there's different ways to manage
different people like when I first when
I first started managing I was basically
managed like I was basically managing
how my director managed me and she was
kind of like with an iron fist
really yeah and it's like don't get our
line do this do that
yeah and it's my way type thing yeah and
I think towards the end of my career
there I was thinking right there's
different ways to manage people some
people need like an arm around them
other people need for the stick and you
and you just had to wet out yourself
yeah pretty much yeah it's almost like
it's a light bulb moment like when you
finally figure that out
sounds simple doesn't it but yeah when
you like especially as you said like you
was in that business early got managed
by the directors so everything is gonna
back up and like obviously you've done
well therefore this light everything
sort of backs up that well with fine
managing the heiglemann as well as a
good chance that they're gonna be yeah
definitely world you know I mean yeah
yeah did you just you just learn that
for trolling largest free light well I
actually this is this isn't working
yeah I just used to trial
couple of things and just see how it did
how it did work or didn't work I was
like I probably won't do that again
yeah and then just yeah just kept going
it's a it's only more recently now that
I've taken more for desire2learn about
management so I listen to like yeah I
listen to a lot of audible now cuz I
hate reading you know like I used to
like it but I just classic don't have
the time to do it so I stick my
headphones in or like when I'm drive to
work now listen to like podcasts or like
management books leadership books all
that sort of thing actually trying to
learn about it yeah pretty much
so yeah so I guess I'm as Thomas Lowe
well actually I mean how can I improve
and get better yeah that's a great thing
now is now I think like if you were to
search for that I'd look for that the
beginning of your career yeah how much
would you have found not sure yeah I
mean it's I think that's that's such a
great thing and so what what I'd really
like to sort of do now mate is I guess
just a fun important that make like
obviously you did really worry progress
the ranks works your absolute socks off
but how how how was your sort of mental
and mindset piece for that you know I
mean because obviously I know now you do
a lot of posts but was you do like
Friday poets like mindset Wednesday yeah
yeah I just do happy mindset day on a
Wednesday in hindsight where like
mentally working long hours tough yeah
you know I mean drinking a lot like you
know I mean like wow how how how was
your mindset and how did that contribute
to yeah success dad you think like
looking back on it I wasn't in a good
headspace really like yeah it was like I
thought I was enjoying my time like it
was going out every Thursday most
Fridays as well like still going to the
gym and everything but not in as much as
what I do now but it was I was stressed
constantly you know and I think just
tired all the time and like I think then
the little things that people around me
would do would just make me snap or
really like yeah or just like make me in
a mood yeah and it's like it's not good
for you
they say yeah how did that start
changing I think God's it was more just
growing up a bit yeah how do you know
31 now yeah yes I think when I start to
get to about I'd say 27 28 was when I
was like I'm not gonna go out every
Thursday Friday it was mainly Thursdays
[Laughter]
you just started working on yourself a
bit yeah pretty much that and then but I
bought a flat and my missus moved in
with me and yeah grounded me yes um yeah
she leave
not that she said you're not going out
or anything but she was like I want you
go to the gym or what we spend time
together and yeah and that which made
more sense yeah
so obviously the position that you are
now in right so you obviously left the
business that you was that obviously a
big part of yeah and you've gone into a
completely different market yeah so
obviously as you said so for like seven
years using the construction engineering
yeah that's where you did all the things
that you've been talking about ready
yeah then you tried something a bit
different yeah and now you're in a yeah
you're ahead of dotnet yeah so we're
talking tech yeah right how was that
transition like that's difficult right
yes I had I'd impostor syndrome I had
two weeks off before I when I left Expo
and joined understanding yeah and I was
getting in my head a little bit I was
like what if I'm not actually like good
at recruitment more yeah I was literally
just like what if I'm not good at
recruitment what if like I've roads the
ranks x4 cuz I was just there yeah it
was just like oh you've been there X
amount get promoted and it was I spoke
to my missus and she was like what the
hell are you on about like you've been
successful you know what you're doing
just trust it so yeah of course he was
worried about yeah I was naturally
because I've been in the same place for
like seven and a half years like it was
the first job out of uni yes you have no
I you have no other things to compare it
yeah exactly
no what now actually I've got a really
good chance yeah yeah
like that so yeah when I when I first
started everyone there was so welcoming
really like that just put my mind at
ease straight away yeah from like from
the moment I went in there for an insuit
even for moment I started talking to one
of the directors like having a telephone
into yours like ah this seems like a a
nice place where I can see myself
working and got in there and yeah
everyone was like right if this is what
we expect you to do I had no target for
three months which I think hell yeah but
I did I'd my first offer two weeks in I
did my first placement like four weeks
in and then yeah then just started yeah
started building from from there some
well this okay so how how how did you
find cuz I'm sure a lot of people think
this I'd love to get sort of your
perspective conveyance on this if I'm a
little quick listening right now what's
one market for three four five years
however maybe you'll see you've got a
real asset there in terms of
relationships and that's like that
really helps you to sort of continue
growing your Billings right yeah so how
have you actually found like basically
just not chucking it all away but like
right I came up start a new chapter
mmm new market new clients like how have
you actually found dealing with that and
that transition yeah I mean I was I was
lucky that I walked into a war market
okay so what makes it warm what is a war
market well I turned up and there was a
load of jobs literally like because
there was one one chap there who reports
into me working all these jobs it was
like yeah we've got ten that need
filling so that was I was just like a
kid in a candy shop
if you're considering a move yeah like
what do you know what you're getting
into
are you starting from completely scratch
yeah are you actually walking it into
natural warm - bah bah blah yeah
obviously that helped yeah so do ya do
your research into it and like if it
isn't a warm desk like find out what
their expectations are yeah for it like
am I expected to bill after a month two
months three months like what's their
actual yeah think of some people like
they have to build a business from
scratch again
and they they might not be doing a deal
replacement for six months or seven
months because they have no relationship
so yeah I definitely definitely advise
doing that and what was that what was
the actual experience of a warm desert
so did that mean that you could call up
and go look and we're never spoken
before work for a business called
understandable yeah he should know or
you was working on the jobs with the
person who was working yeah you say I'll
work with such-and-such
yeah yeah it was literally just that an
illness yeah and it was yeah just what
sauce basically really yeah so I said
well I started doing that but I was
wanting to be D at the same time so I
was like right I want to get my own
businesses and yeah like relationships
established than that so stop and then
how have you found like the technical
part
have you found picking the heart yeah I
did some research into it yeah like when
they said are you gonna be head of
dotnet by two weeks off as I said so I
was googling like what is C sharp
what is dotnet yeah I put dot net
developer into the job boards just to
look at other people's adverts smart and
just was like our rights of this and
this like c-sharp asp.net etc etc and
then Google what that would be and then
go on LinkedIn and see if I could find
developers with that skill set just yet
before yeah awesome before you start
just doing just doing some searching
myself and seeing how it would work and
then the way I learned about the tech
was asking candidates mmm like yeah just
literally like I'm new to I'm new to
tech recruitment I've got eight years
recruitment experience but I know what
I'm doing but I don't know what this
particular market is and I just ask the
candidates what is this and how by the
majority if it was like received quite
well because I was just open and honest
with them yeah cuz I said I said look
this is a company we're working with
this is what the role is
like talk to me about your experience
with that and if they were like oh yeah
I've done that for years I'm like okay
cool what does that actually mean so I
don't know what it means
yeah and yeah some of them will just
like go away but other like go away put
me for the role others were just like
the majority firm we're just happy to
chat
and then you just got better better ya
understand then yeah because I'd always
like I started doing mechanical design
recruitment then I'd like my team grew
into electrical quality like production
process I said yeah this was at x4 so I
kind of had to learn about different
things I've I think I just naturally
evolved into having that right figure
out what it is
ya know that's been spoken about before
so that don't be afraid to ask stupid
questions yeah yeah yeah and be as you
said I think that that's definitely the
way that you should play it right just
be honest and transparent Eilert this is
my experience this is where I'm at yeah
I'd love to find out a bit more about
what you've been up to in your
experience does their yeah hopefully
seven eight times out of ten hmm they
say they say yeah you know what this is
what's going on larger and blah blah
blah and on the next call great you've
got a couple more words and nuances you
understand now that you can then use the
next one yeah exactly that
okay mate so then she'd been there from
when did you say June July July laughs
yeah yeah yeah you've been denied
Billings well December I did 60 yeah
which was solid I think I'm about 120
and 60 is that your biggest month yeah
that's my biggest month in my career to
be really yeah like why do you think
that is why do you think like nearly
like nearly 10 years into your career in
60k brand new market yeah brand new job
brand new agency yeah I mean I think it
was more like because I started managing
from an early stage in my career yeah
and then I was getting more and more off
the phones like as the years were going
through yeah but yeah I don't know like
I had my last place I'd 35k months 40k
months but never quite like 16 yeah yeah
especially in a December I was like this
is this is sick and why why do you think
that is I don't know I just I think it
was just literally that was all the
stars were aligned with everything like
every every company I was getting into
used with like one of them got the job
they all took it and it wasn't about
that
yeah exactly exactly like there's only
been since I've been there there's only
been one month that I've blanked really
yeah and then like I did I think I did
two deals too like the first and second
for the next month anyway so it's just
like yeah a cyclical so business
development mmm what's been you know
sort of relationship with that and how
you how have you is done with that so
clearly so you of someone that ya wanted
to get your own jobs and stuff like that
yeah so like how is that how how's that
being a more of being your sort of
learnings or challenges with that it's
different now to what I was doing with
engineering but in Tex Tex definitely
very different cuz engineering it was
just 100% foam base it was just
literally add as many businesses and
managers to the database and call them
like yeah call them called and called
him that's how I used to pick pick jobs
up but now it's like and then I was more
focused on relationship building now
it's I still office Leanne phone based
burn some the majority from don't answer
define so it's like yeah so it's
literally like I'll try and connect them
on LinkedIn or send them an email or
I'll send them an email but then I
always follow up with a phone call and I
think that's what people need to be
doing to be successful in BD is making
sure that you're getting on the phone
with him here different touch points in
the air on Drive phone comes yeah and
then meetings and then just cement it
from there so before we left x4 was that
still very much the approach to win
clients just get on the phone and like
yeah
yeah pretty much finally a phone based
stuff they didn't like didn't have a
recruit a license at that point they
might do now or deny yeah mine was just
LinkedIn premium account yeah which was
like we're not when I first got to
understand it oh you got a recruit
licenses like cool what the hell don't
do with it I didn't know about like
yeah yeah so so have you adapted
something because you've never done that
before
yeah you're someone that's obviously
from my concern line trying to embrace
doing different things so quickly
realize that while actually I'm just
mashing the switchboard and stuff isn't
gave me a lot of success here yeah how
what yeah how have you found that like
approaching it differently I just try
different things and just really let's
see if it works it works if it doesn't
it doesn't but I'm not someone who's
like oh I'll try it once and then if it
doesn't work I'll never do it again cuz
like it might take five or six ten
hundred attempts doing the same thing
with different people to see how it how
you get on with it so what have been
some of the most effective ways so far
done for you
LinkedIn insights LinkedIn in some years
is that so if you've got like given all
the secrets yes on premium I think it's
on some premier counts or like the
recruiter accounts you can view like
their business and how like where their
degrees come from or like where their
staff come from that's it I think you've
got to pay more for that ya think so so
you can do like we do stuff like that so
you so that's a tool that's been a
pretty effective yeah so that's been
quite fit yeah that's one so you'd be
able to look at a company and go are so
there's a lot of people with this
certain degree or there's lots of unions
if I can find so that helps you then
understand what the top of people
usually yes I went yeah and when I speak
to them over the phone or on an email I
will literally say oh I've looked at
this through LinkedIn and I see that you
take on people from this uni or this
unit here like why is that and just
asking and I don't like that yeah yeah
it's not just like our specialising
dotnet development yeah can i that's a
job I like the thing is in today's world
as you know recruiting and tech light
can have all the best tip if you don't
utilize it will actually use it
yeah yeah well I don't know hand in
people listening right now have limbs
and in science but I think you
definitely be paying some cash for those
things but that's interesting so you've
been using that so that's hell yeah
that's helped and just yeah more like
more presents on LinkedIn's helped like
posting
mindset things really helped me cuz I
have a lot of people connecting to me
like I really like that's an awesome
post like some some still don't comment
on it but they'll connect to me and just
like I hear that really resonated with
me I'm right alright thank you very much
but how does that actually what in terms
of how is it how is it how is a
recruiter I think it gets you profile
out there more and it just shows that
you're not the same recruiter like if
you put dotnet into LinkedIn they'll be
like so many likes blanket things or
just like carbon copies of specialized
in dotnet especially so many yeah
exactly and just like constantly posting
oh I've got this job or a job just like
one of my best mates as developer and he
was like I [ __ ] hate that he's like
the amount of people I've disconnected
from just because it's like new job new
job a new job he's like yeah I'm not I'm
not about that so it's like just mixing
up what you're posting really hell and
that's what enables you to build
relationships with people will stand out
basically yeah exactly that but then
you've gotten the foeman these people
right yeah yeah one of the scent like if
as soon as someone likes my post I'll
connect to him light and say thanks for
liking my post by what did you like
about it anything like always like
getting feedback so I asked them for
that and then I post I post some tech
stuff as well so like I try and think
about what what like the clients would
want to see what the can be seen and
then just anyone who likes that I
connect to them and thanks and just
spark off conversation yes and just
final thing on that mentally this is the
sort what I'm in but it's it's right
here some nasod perspective on that hmm
if I'm listen what now going yeah odds
mate I'll just I'll just smash the
phones now alright yeah don't work me
just like so how is actually the
practicalities so it hasn't enabled you
to be more effective on BD
has it I don't know you know I mean what
has it actually really helped you with
unlike the day-to-day in your
recruitment job this which is why it's
worth thinking about or trying things
it's it's like some some hiring managers
or like internal recruiters have
actually connected to you like if
they've liked your posts you connect to
them
and they're like oh yeah some even say I
don't normally connect with recruiters
or I don't normally accept connection
requests but I really liked what you
said and then that just sparks a
conversation yeah and you don't have to
say all right give me your jobs yeah
like you use that as an insight into
them find out what like find out what
their need is long always as he said
pain points I always used to think about
beady and objection handling is like
someone having a suit of armor on
because that's what I got tore yeah and
it's like find out where the wheat way
is and then just yeah and then just go
in there yeah so that I think that's
fair so what enable you to do is have
conversations with people with typically
people that again pestered all the time
getting petted by people that look the
same and very quickly because you've
been willing to sort of share a bit
around ours and what you're passionate
about you're interested in that it's
enable you to drive conversations with
people that give you an opportunity to
go long-term like yeah this is what you
know we do here at blah blah blah yeah
exactly yeah exactly yeah that's that's
cool mate but I think to run the office
like it's got it's got to be a company
way of being proactive yeah yeah if you
just post on LinkedIn for the sake of
postin yeah like yeah it's all well and
good that you'll get some profile views
but what are you doing yeah yeah you've
got to pick up the phone yeah exactly
yeah yeah so if you're not doing
anything with it then yeah it is
pointless but it's another way of
selling people don't realise it's
selling how long what so now sort of
through all your experiences now how
have you like really approached
management and growing your team now any
sort of key things there that you
thought was really important to you
because you said earlier obviously
understood
I just can't manage I run the same way
yeah in Latin what's a lot really
important you know as a manager you're
clearly learning about it any sort of
insights there yeah more patients like
that that has to be it and just I think
every time I hired people in the past I
just expected them to be good from day
one and and it then took me like no you
got to remember yeah remember you were
[ __ ] once
yeah and that's an that sort of thing so
it's yeah just having the patience but
being being there when they need you but
giving them independent straight away
mmm because it's like let them find
their feet let them [ __ ] up mmm it's not
like they gonna kill anyone is it they
might make them worse if enough yeah
they might make him estate they might
like we we have people just start as
resources understanding so yeah it's not
like they're going to lose a client or
anything like that so yeah it's lame
accountability yeah yeah allow these
people to fail and I'm assuming then is
your job then to be like right what can
we do better next year and what did you
learn from that and sort of cultivate
that yeah and be more for being more of
a coach and a mentor as a poet and a
leader as opposed to a manager so not
just like oh you'll be doing this at
this time this at this time this at this
time it's right I think you should be
doing this or what do you think you
should be doing what's worked well for
you what hasn't worked well for you
awesome
and then yeah growing my team now it's
just making sure I hire the right people
lives I've gone from a massive team of
20 people to you know to now it's like I
want to grow it again and it being
sustainable when you are you in complete
control of that light in terms of like
who you hire yeah one of really yeah
yeah so the director still have a say on
who comes into the business obviously
but if I'm like I don't feel like I want
this person there's a very good chance
thing in this yeah yeah always get asked
around sort of hiring they obviously
there's so much challenges for business
owners and managers on hiring for their
team like what are the fear from your
perspective what they're non-negotiable
is when you're looking to hire your team
but what are these people will have to
have or do you need to see YouTube light
I want to give this person a chance
counter Billy accountability yeah and
like just evidence off that okay and
also resilience as well that's like a
that's a main one ability how'd you look
for that just like just with how they
answer questions as well if they're like
if you can tell they're like bending the
truth a little bit or if you can just
tell something it's not sitting right
and you probe with them mmm if they hold
the hands up and go yeah you know what
I'm actually
it'll be a crap yeah then okay that's
actually that is worse for me yeah but
if they're like oh yeah I've been the
best thing since sliced bread and I'll
do this and I'd do that and you know you
haven't have you
yeah and then they're just like no I'm
off you pop ha ha how do you how do you
try and identify resilience in people
just ask about like their life ask about
where they think they've struggled
before and like how they piss like
persevered and and got through it
like some people like just give our
being a keen sportsman and like we lost
a game and then we picked ourselves off
I was like that's not really resilient
like I've had other some people who I've
hired before who have literally come
from nothing like hadn't been on holiday
outside the UK before before joining and
hitting a holiday target like that sort
of thing like really struggling with
finance and and what-have-you and like
stuff like that resonates with me
because yeah like Ivan my family have
been like comfortable and fairly
well-off but like I've not come from
like a mansion or anything like that my
father struggled through like working
that so I've seen those struggles so
that resonate yeah so it's just it's
literally just having something about
you where you will not just like you're
not just the same person or a carbon
copy if it likes someone else really
okay and before we finish then couple of
news I guess just around the Hoff then
for for anyone listening the maybe over
the next couple years a long time made
me think I'm right like do I do I see
myself at this agency for then there's
sort of two three years not sure the
next decade or in 2020 now a bla just
from your experiencing because if that
can be also really daunting daunting any
time moving a job right but particularly
for those people that have been in one
agency for a while whatever what what
would be your sort of go-to advice on if
you're considering a move maybe
completely different market when a
complete new start new business what
yeah and any advice just to sort of key
things to look out for
yeah I'd say take your time when looking
don't just jump ship for the sake of
jumping like I never it was never that I
thought how the grass is gonna be
greener somewhere else I was just like
I've done what I have done here and I
just thought it was naturally time for
me to move on yeah so yeah don't rush
but do you research get a wreck to wreck
I used I had a couple of other inches
other than understanding I went to
understanding direct but like the rector
X can advise you on what companies you
actually should be going for you do your
own research and then just ask as many
questions as possible throughout the
whole in issue stage any expectation
one's a big one isn't that yeah like
what okay if I joined tomorrow why are
the actual expectations of me yeah one
understand yeah yeah find out like are
you expected to build straightaway are
you expected to pick up clients like
what happens if you don't yeah like find
all all of that because that's gonna
help you your mind at ease as well as in
that yeah not have as much pressure on
yourself
yeah so it can also be hard when you've
got like that amount of experience
behind you going into new company yeah
yes obviously I was in the big dog man
and now you gotta build those
relationships you know I mean yeah
exactly and it's having that it's having
that pressure as well I've got mortgage
I've got a lot of outgoings and all that
sort of thing so that was that billing
when there's a recruitment lifestyle
yeah paid a few you need that yeah
really yeah awesome
I paid that off about three four years
ago really yeah that was good yeah it
was it was a nice touch when I knew it
was the final one yeah that must be a
good feeling yeah it was counting down
there cuz it just keep just keep eating
away at your like monthly wage doesn't
yeah yeah exactly so it's um it's like
basically like another tax yeah so I
used to see tax ni and thence to hire
and there was there were some months
where they're taking like 1500 1700 quid
out of my like pay and I must be so
painful
yeah cuz I imagine when this is finally
thing oh I've got all that cash it's
just interesting more than that war I
have a view of the
it's come up a couple of times but like
did you have you had any advice or what
what's been your sort of relationship
with like earning more money - no I mean
because come you need there or that yeah
obviously that again when you were young
and again back to so you went out a lot
and then you change and stuff but mhm
don't I have you what's been your
experience in light deny have you plan
obviously taught me obviously before we
started that you're in the process of
buying the home which um so like what's
been your relation have you sort of
grown up with like your finances as well
yeah 100%
really like when I first started I think
probably the first three or four years I
spent every penny I own like I literally
would empty my bank account and my mom
and dad did actually yeah but you don't
your mom and dad son use that yeah
that's exactly what happened like I
literally just went you know I'll just
do me I've worked hard for them yeah
exactly so like thinking about it if I
had started saving even a little bit
yeah I would have had a flat a couple of
years earlier I would have had this
house probably a couple years earlier
that that's not like don't enjoy about
this yeah definitely conversation we
have to be had there when you start and
in good money in recruitment and you're
young you're in London typically or
wherever in the city
yeah who's tending to say well I should
let do your thing but if I was in your
shoes I'd be thinking about this and
just plant those seeds that you can make
your own decision on
well actually I'm gonna start saving 2%
on my monthly wage every time gonna pull
it in this type of bank account and
that's going to mean that you know I
mean I think there's such a conversation
to be had there yeah you know I mean
yeah I think so and it's it's things
that ice do now with like with my new
lad in really excited I was like what
your guy was just like I want to buy a
house buy a time on 26 and like right
cool and how do you how are you going to
get there like how much do you need to
save each month yes get it what what
what property prices are you looking at
like where are you looking at how many
bedrooms yeah and it then gets them like
picturing what it is so then actually
becomes tangible yeah that's good I'm
assuming that helps you might have a
mine he's a la Donna get on the phone
you said you wanted to get that house
make work out
that's how I did it I wanted when I
first started either 1.6 golf that year
my mom had given me yeah and like I
dragged it around once at uni I was like
right I want to be mw1 say yes and as
[ __ ] as it sounds I printed a photo of
that car that I really and stuck it on
me yeah I just stuck it on my monitor so
everyday I was looking at yeah that's
why I'm doing this job that's why I'm
getting told to go away 20 times a day
yeah and what have you I love that
before we finished me as you know you'll
run you'll come to the event on you oh
yes yeah so got a couple of questions on
resilience yeah with the event coming up
so I've got three questions for you and
then I'm gonna ask you what you're
excited about how she'd find a question
so first question what what does
resilience in recruitment mean to you to
me is literally just sticking out it and
being accountable with it so if you
you'll have good days and you have bad
days and like you love good months and
bad month
it's like it's just digging deep and
trusting in the process and thinking
yeah you know what there is gonna be
light at the end of the tunnel having
that about you trusting the process a
lot yeah an interesting one this one
it's got some interesting answers so how
in your opinion how has the importance
or needs for resilience changed as the
industry's evolved I think yeah I think
it's come it's come a little bit coming
a little bit down like especially when
there's different areas of recruitment
now it's not you don't have to do a full
360 role you could start 118 stars I'm
really sore so you can go into talent
acquisition you can go internal hmm so
like you don't really have to be
resilient in as much in an internal role
or talent acquisition to a 360 BD
sourcing model so see you think there's
from when you first started to now hmm
the sort of environment you're in that
maybe requires less resilient yeah
to an extent yeah I think yeah I think
it depends what
type of business you're in yeah like
they'll still be some that are literally
like cutthroat business yes and you've
got to be like yes marginal yeah exactly
that but it's definitely evolved right
and I think yeah it's I think it's like
resilience in sort of slightly different
ways now that might be not getting any
in mail replies yeah you know I mean
it's slightly different maybe compared
to when you is in that office with the
free directors and you were getting
point black now a bit different this
sort of resilience you mean when you get
no luck from your post I mean different
experiences experience what residents
now deaf you can still you're gonna get
rejected and all that but yeah okay last
one what be interested what you say
about this so what what do you think and
what do you do in terms of what can
people do themselves to instill more
resilience or what can people do
themselves to instill resilience in
their teams by what yeah what sort of
things do you do so for me I just I
always used to think about like the
negatives of everyday and I was like oh
this went to [ __ ] this went to [ __ ] and
I'm like I didn't actually think about
the positives okay and I've just now
started like what I've been doing it for
a while with like every time I go home
or like first thing in the morning I
visualize my morning I visualized like
when I'm in the shower like how am i day
is gonna go love that so I'm like right
this this person's gonna get this job
I'm gonna get in twos with this yeah
like even when I had the offer
acceptable in the house like I woke up
in the morning I was like right I'm
gonna hear today that this offer to
accept them like that sort of thing and
then on the either going home or on the
way home I'm like what did I actually
get out this day that was good mmm right
right of this win well this went well
like even if even if it's like art 5 in
males accepted yeah like or I'd a decent
beat equal like just take the little
wins and they'll then build into the big
wins I like that and then like when you
do deal was like actually revel in it a
little bit yeah always like solo yeah so
what you always looking bored
cream and onion yeah we're gonna bill
next month yeah I'm gonna do this
yeah you've become better instead of
you've become better focusing on well
actually I did have a [ __ ] horrible
day but I did you bear it sort of
focusing on the positive sauce yeah you
know that can be difficult to do right I
won understand yeah because you can so
difficult to do yeah because like one
one girl in in in the office she was
like oh I've had a really [ __ ] day today
didn't you just put 15k in yeah just
like yeah but I didn't get nice even
[Music]
again it sounds quite simple but it was
such an empowering moment and
realization that you're in complete
control of what you focus on yeah and it
sounds really simple but like there's a
lot of people out there that if someone
cuts them up on their way into work like
that's a day ruined yeah yeah and it
used to be me
yeah yeah and it's like I've been on my
own journey with that bit is such a when
you realize that obviously we're all
prone to being like people [ __ ] you
are from I think when you really realize
that you're all completely accountable
to how you react how you feel about
things like that's down to you that's
not down to the candidate dropping out
that's not down to the it's not down to
the person cutting you up in a traffic
light that is down to you and that is
really empowering that massively helps
in recruitment you're not I mean if you
feel colleague yeah drives into work
someone cuts them up and they're few men
and they're fuming for the most of the
day yeah mate like they're a
disadvantage yeah 100 sir not me how so
that's what you do for yourself and a
failure for your team that how have you
tried to call about that then your team
yeah yeah wanted to sense I literally I
celebrate the wins with it like so if we
have if we have a good week or if you
have a good month or I will go to the
pub or like go go for a meal or or
what-have-you and just yeah I just
didn't still like they ask me about my
life experience and that because you
know what I've known for a couple of
months the other I've known for seven
months so it's just this is still in
that game know me face so I guess it is
it to be fair it comes back to that if
you're if you'll call it comes to you
guys about the like if you ask them
right how was your day English it me
yeah and then this your job than to
blood right okay
fair but what what do you do that you're
happy with today yeah exactly yeah those
lots of things yeah so it's like why was
it [ __ ] all right what could you have
done to make it better you and then
finish with what was actually good
yeah and that and that yeah okay a lot
here so before final question mmm were
you excited about my and what's going on
in 2024 the.net team were you excited
grow for the expansion more than he
knows yes I've got plans to hire at
least two maybe three others this year
also and just yet
I want it because I'm now back to
billing and managing I just want to have
like a monster year so like I want it
yeah so I'm like that six yeah 60 came
on twenty last month already on ten for
this most it's like I'm yeah I'm aiming
for 360 400 this year really yeah yeah
set myself back on the podcast myself
done because what's built what's been
your biggest year today because today
was like 205 really like near enough
double it yeah so yeah so that's the
that's the plan and then yeah just grow
and just sustainable growth and make
sure everyone that knows what they're
doing they know why they're here they
know what they're doing it for and and
that and just yeah helping drive the
business forward awesome
last question hmm if Arjun could
communicate to every single recruiter
out there I'd listen they take on your
advice could be a phrase a sentence or
words what you want to tell these people
thing and then listen process that's the
price to trust the process literally
like figure out what you need to do what
needs to make you successful in
recruitment and just do it over and over
again trust the process
yeah I wasn't spending pleasure man last
one yes